- [Narrator] Meet David Aguilar.
- [Narrator] When David was born,
his right arm hadn't fully developed.
- [Narrator] And while some would see this
as a disadvantage, David
is just a regular kid.
He likes EDM.
He goes by the name, Hand Solo.
Get it?
He has an embarrassing dad.
He goes to school.
And, he can open doors with his Lego arm.
So cool.
Growing up, he was obsessed with Lego.
So much so, he wanted to make
it a part of him, literally.
- [Narrator] Unfortunately,
the Lego bricks
weren't strong enough and it
wasn't for another nine years
'til he would try again.
- [Narrator] That model,
the MK1, only took five days
to build, of course,
like any good inventor,
he got straight to work on an upgrade.